noah on s'affaire dans les salles du
château quelques professionnels sont au
travail pour la partie technique mais
l'essentiel de la troupe est constituée
de bénévoles près de 800 au total lancé
dans un incroyable marathon
leur mission consistait à effectuer sept
cent cinquante représentations du
fabuleux noël du château en quatre
week-ends un exploit accompli grâce à la
totale adhésion du groupe
c'est une aventure assez assez
extraordinaire et puis ça permet de se
dépasser
ça permet de ce fait de fédérer les gens
entre eux d'avoir une continuité de
faire vivre le chaton aussi parce que
c'est un peu une belle envie un château
comme ça c'est c'est le château qui sont
en rayon il s'est endormi et laon
l'arrêt depuis quatre ans il
[Musique]
ce coup de massue
le spectacle d'environ une heure évoque
la vie de madame de maintenon favorite
du roi louis xiv le roi soleil lui
octroya la somme nécessaire à l'achat du
château de maintenant en 16 174 et en
fit secrètement son épouse en 783 cette
trajectoire étonnante et compter dans ce
spectacle pour petits et grands dont le
château de maintenant est à la fois
l'écrin est la vedette
le chaton de maintenant il intervient
assez tard dans l'asile madame de
maintenon puisqu'elle l'acquiert quand
elle est déjà introduite à la cour et
c'est ici qu'elle va venir elle va il se
resserre de nombreux travaux avant la
montespan va accoucher de certains
enfants de louis xiv qu'en fait le
château de maintenon et là comme un coq
sommes ainsi l'historique de l'histoire
qu'on raconte tableau
ce spectacle existe depuis 2015 et à
trouver son public
chaque hiver il attire près de 20000
visiteurs ce qui en fait l'événement
culturel majeur du département
d'eure-et-loir en fin d'année
[Musique]